dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly fare today we are
going to talk about a task that humans
are remarkably good at but learning
algorithms mostly flounder and that is
creating 3d geometry by looking at a 2d
color image in video games and animation
films this is a scenario that comes up
very often if we need a new weapon model
in the game we typically give the artist
a photo will sit down with a 3d modeler
program and spend a few hours sculpting
a similar 3d geometry and I will quickly
note that our binocular vision is not
entirely necessary to make this happen
we can look at 2d images all day long
and still have a good idea about the
shape of an airplane even with one eye
closed
we have previous episodes on this
problem and the verdict was that the
results with previous techniques are
great but not very detailed
mathematicians like to say that this
algorithm has a cubic complexity or
cubic scaling which means that if we
wish to increase the resolution of the
3d model just a tiny bit we have to wait
not a tiny bit longer but significantly
longer and the cubic part means that
this trade-off becomes unbearable even
for moderately high resolutions this
paper offers a technique to break
through this limitation this new
technique still uses a learning
algorithm to predict the geometry when
it creates these 3d models
hierarchically this means that it starts
out approximating the course geometry of
the output and restarts the process by
adding more and more fine details to it
the geometry becomes more and more
refined over several steps now this
refinement doesn't just work unless we
have a carefully designed algorithm
around it the refinement happens by
using additional information in each
step from the created model namely we
imagine our predicted 3d geometry as a
collection of small blocks and each
block is classified as either free space
occupied space or as a surface after
this classification happened we have the
possibility to focus our efforts on
refining the surface of the model
leading to a significant improvement in
the execution time of the algorithm
as a result we get 3d models that are of
higher quality than the ones offered by
previous techniques the outputs are
still not super high resolution but they
capture a fair number of surface detail
and you know the drill research is a
process and every paper is a stepping
stone and this is one of those stepping
stones that can potentially save many
hours of work for 3d artists in the
industry thanks for watching and for
your generous support now see you next
time
[Music]